my name is Melissa Van Buell and I'm an
analyst at statistics Canada which is
the official statistical agency of
Canada today I'll be talking about how
my team converted our documentation to
Cordo and doing this conversion was
definitely a
journey not all Journeys go according to
plan but before I get into the details
of how we did this conversion I want to
first start by sharing a story about
another Journey that didn't go according
to
plan I want to take you all back to the
DIY era of the covid-19
pandemic during that time my housemate
and I decided to build our own outdoor
couch we found this template online
which looked
doable we bought the wood from the
blueprint and coughed up the $85 Home
Depot delivery fee because we didn't
have a car that would fit the wood in
it but as soon as we got the wood
delivered we quickly realized that the
saw we had wasn't exactly going to cut
it so we needed to borrow a better saw
from a family friend this made
everything so much more efficient and we
managed to finish building the
couch or so we thought
it turns out that the instructions that
we've been following were actually only
for the part of the couch that was
missing an arm we had only purchased
half of the wood that we
needed so we needed to head back to Home
Depot and we bought the rest of the wood
that we
needed there was just one problem left
we still didn't have a car that would
fit all the wood in it and we had paid
that $85 delivery fee the first time
time but we really didn't want to pay
that
again so we borrowed a truck from a
friend in order to get the rest of the
wood
home once we had the right tools and all
the resources and help that we needed we
were able to successfully finish
building the
couch this journey full of unexpected
challenges is very similar to the
journey that my team had when converting
our documentation to
Cordo
today I'll share that Journey with you
as well as the challenges that we faced
along the way I'll also share some tips
and tricks that we used all of which are
applicable to any kind of Cordo
project I'm going to start by providing
some necessary
context I work on a team at statistics
Canada that publishes statistics related
to education in
Canada there's a lot of domain knowledge
and subject matter as well as
methodological Concepts that need to be
documented
somewhere this leads to a very important
distinction in the title of my
talk when I say the word documentation
I'm not talking about our package
documentation I'm talking about
documentation that defines terms like
these so it's really the subject matter
documentation and not the package
documentation I'm talking about the sort
of information that somebody might put
in a Wiki or on Confluence or something
like
that whatever you call yours we call
ours a user guide and for us it was
previously stored as a 120 page Word
document scrolling through this document
was slow and only one person could edit
it at a time which was a significant
challenge for our large
team our Version Control was limited to
the track changes feature in word which
made it pretty challenging to follow
updates over
time after last year's conference we
discovered Cordo which would address
those challenges that we had been facing
with
word when we started this conversion
though we were all total beginners with
Cordo this meant that in order for us to
effectively complete this task we would
need to use the right tools
when you're working with Cordo there are
so many tools that you can use to make
your life
easier if you're looking to convert
existing text to Cordo a good first step
is to convert the text to markdown first
if it's not already in that
format we used the pandoc convert
function from the our markdown package
to automatically convert our Word
document from word format to
markdown this provided us a really great
starting
point although this was a great starting
point it was still just a starting point
there were still a lot of formatting
changes that we need needed to
make in order to make this part of the
job easier we set up custom keyboard
shortcuts in our
idees for example we set up a shortcut
that made it a little bit easier to
convert uh urls into valid markdown
links if you're using R Studio as your
IDE you can also set up code Snippets
which are a great way to automate code
insertion for anything that you find
yourself typing out very
frequently this is great for when you
want to use some of the cool Cordo
features that take a little bit longer
to type
out I really recommend checking out Tom
Mox GitHub gist that contains code
Snippets that are very useful for
working with Cordo those code Snippets
are provided for both our studio and vs
code for any syntax that's a little bit
trickier to type out there are ways to
avoid doing things
manually personally I find the Syntax
for markdown tables to be extremely
finicky our studios's visual editor
comes in great handy for this or you can
also find similar tools online if you're
using different
idees for situations like these
generative AI is another great option
both chat GPT and GitHub co-pilot have a
pretty decent knowledge of Cordo syntax
but an even better understanding of HTML
and
CSS you can use generative AI for a
variety of use cases but you'll find it
particularly helpful for making your
Cordo projects more
aesthetic if you're looking to use these
tools I've got a video on my YouTube
channel that explains how to use chat
GPT and GitHub co-pilot as an arm
programmer once you're done with
creating the content there's something
that you can do to make maintaining the
content easier as well you can use git
for proper Version Control and you can
use either GitHub actions or G lab
pipelines to automate the publishing of
your
content this will make it so that every
single time you make a commit using git
the published version of your content
will be automatically updated without
you having to do
anything I promise that this is much
easier than it sounds and I've got
videos on my YouTube channel that give
examples of Cordo pipelines using both
GitHub actions and gitlab Pipelines
or if you prefer to avoid the whole
pipeline thing Al together and you're
just looking for somewhere to host your
Cordo content for free I've also got a
video that explains how to use Cordo Pub
to publish a website in under a
minute there are so many great tools for
working with Cordo but there are
probably still going to be some times
when you need a little bit of extra help
there's probably going to come a point
where you want to do something and you
don't know how to do that thing whenever
that happens you can ask the r Community
for
help when it comes to asking Cordo
questions there's an order of operations
that I like to
follow of course you should always start
by checking the Cordo documentation and
Googling your problem to see if
somebody's already made a video a blog
post or posted on stack Overflow about
it but if you can't find find what
you're looking for there you can also
reach out to your colleagues or friends
including the ones you make while here
at conf you can also reach out to your
local R user group or your R ladies
chapter if you have
one in fact if there's anyone in the
audience from Ottawa the Our Ladies
Ottawa chapter will be having our first
event in 3 years coming up next Tuesday
September
26th in our case last summer though we
were among the first to be using Cordo
in our area which meant that we
sometimes needed to seek help using
other
avenues Twitter is a great place for
this especially if you use the hashtags
R stats and Cordo Pub for example I
tweeted this asking if there's a clever
way to render Cordo documents to PDF if
the HTML version contains
gifts within an hour someone had
responded to my question explaining that
there's a way to make content visible or
invisible depending on the format of the
output another great place that you can
ask your Cordo questions is by using the
Q&A feature on the discussions portion
of the Cordo CLI GitHub
repo this is where the development for
CTO happens and when you post a question
in the Q&A here it might be answered by
a member of the r Community or maybe
even a member of the Cordo development
team
itself personally I found the Q&A
feature to be an incredible resource
there's been times where I've been
stumped on Syntax for multiple days and
I feel just about ready to give up but
then I post the question on the Q&A and
I'm able to get an answer within the
same
day for example we needed to create a
bilingual Cordo website that would allow
the user to switch between English and
French to do this we created a Cordo
project that had an English folder and a
French folder with identical file
structure using the Cordo documentation
we were able to find a way to create a
toggle that would allow the user to
switch between the two
languages the only problem was that when
the user would click the button it would
take them back to the home page rather
than displaying the current page in the
opposite
language we asked about this in the
Cordo Q&A and it was suggested that we
use JavaScript to create a button that
would modify the URL when
clicked after following an example that
was provided in in the comments of that
Q&A we were able to successfully uh
create this button and we now have a
fully bilingual CTO
website as you become more and more
advanced with
CTO you might find yourself asking
questions that are actually
unanswerable and what I mean by that is
that there might be features that you're
looking for that aren't Curr Curr
implemented in
Cordo after all it is still pretty
new if this is the case there's a good
chance that someone from the Cordo
development team will comment on your
Q&A indicating that this is the case or
they might suggest a clever workaround
instead you can also check to see if
there's already been a feature request
for whatever you're trying to do and if
not you can create one
yourself personally I find this to be
one of the coolest things about using
Cordo especially at this point in time
even as an end user of Cordo you could
have the opportunity to help shape the
future of
Cordo once we had a working first draft
it was time to share our project more
broadly with
others this is where we faced our third
Challenge and where you're likely to
face a challenge too although you might
be super passionate about Cordo and
confident in its potential it is still a
pretty new product and not everyone is
going to be on board on day
one getting that support for Cordo can
be challenging and the approach that you
take May differ depending on your target
audience with management a good strategy
is to show not tell rather than starting
a conversation about Cordo create a cool
project using Cordo that will wow
people when someone inevitably asks you
how you made it this is when you can
talk about what Cordo
is depending on your workplace you may
have the additional challenge of CTO not
currently being on the list of
installable
software in our case Last Summer we
didn't have access to a version of our
studio that came prepackaged with
Cordo instead we needed to use vs code
as our editor while we waited for our
version of our studio to be
updated another option is to use rocker
which is a Docker image that comes
prepackaged with
Cordo in order to get your colleagues on
board with Cordo I highly suggest
creating templates that you or anyone
else can use as a starting point for
their project not only is this going to
prevent you from needing to reinvent the
wheel every time but it'll also reduce
the barriers that others might face when
trying to learn a new
tool you can either start with a
pre-existing template for example from
the awesome Cordo repo on GitHub or you
can create your own for example I
created this Statistics Canada theme for
the reveal.js
format for any colleagues who don't have
get or markdown experience a great way
to enable enable collaboration is to use
the report issue feature on your Cordo
projects with just a single click of a
button a new issue can be created on the
Project's gitlab or GitHub repo and the
necessary changes can be described in
plain text using a what you see is what
you get type of text editor this then
makes it very easy for the developer to
go in and copy paste the uh
modifications that need to be made with
little to no modification on their end
allowing for Effective collaboration
across the
board and finally you can also enable
word and PDF formats for any end users
who might prefer those formats over
HTML once we had the right tools and all
of the resources and help that we needed
we were able to successfully convert our
user guide from word to Cordo and we now
have documentation that feels amazing to
developers and users
alike Eric who's a developer appreciates
how easy it is to automatically generate
our documentation in three different
formats using just a single commit and
Sylvie who's an end user of the
documentation appreciates that Cordo
websites are easy and pleasant to use
and that creating an issue Whenever
there are typos is
straightforward
at statistics Canada more broadly Cordo
is now a pretty popular tool not only
has my team continued to use it for any
new projects that we start but other
teams have started to adopt it as well
for example the website for statistics
Canada's R and python user group or R
pug for short was recently converted
from Hugo to Cordo training resources
for teaching people about R and data
bricks have also been created using
Cordo and at the individual level
analysts have started using the reveal
JS format to create stunning
presentations I hope that with these
tips and tricks you're able to have a
successful project whether that's
adopting Cordo or completing your own
DIY thank
[Applause]
you